dark wings dark words I was only a boy
when the Raven came to call my father
Lord Eddard Stark to another war Balin
Greyjoy had raised the Iron Islands in
revolt and burned the Lannister fleet at
anchor King Robert Baratheon again
needed his old friend my mother Catelyn
was not happy to lose her Lord husband
to Robert again six years before he had
left her to avenge his father and
brother against the Mad King but now he
had sons and daughters of his own and
unspoken another son who wasn't hers
from the last time he went to war my
brother Jon Snow but she knew then
marrying my father she had married the
north we hold our honor and duty as dear
as our old gods when the time came my
father marched south to restore peace
and order to the realm my father always
told me the Iron Islands were a strange
and dangerous place its people the
Ironborn keep neither the old gods nor
the seven and despised all or honest oil
their ancestors ravaged the western
shores raping and slaving and putting it
to the torch and their song still ringed
through the halls of the Ironborn while
everywhere else there whispered to
wayward children at bedtime perhaps Lord
Balin thought Westeros had not healed
from the war against the Mad King and
was as fragmented and suspicious as the
ancient kingdoms his forebears had
terrorized Roberts Navy corrected him at
Fair Isle when they smashed the proud
iron fleet Robert and my father
corrected him at Pyke his own castle
when they pulled down his towers and
breached his walls my father never liked
to speak of his battles but from other
men I learned what transpired Thoris of
Mir was first through the breach with
his flaming sword not far behind him was
Jorah Mormont of Bear Island
my father's bannermen who earned the
knighthood he would later shame and
Lords from every corner of the Seven
Kingdoms all day through every passage
in the castle they
for side-by-side my father with our
ancestral sword ice and King Robert with
his Warhammer against a horde of
ax-wielding Ironborn in the end Lord
Balin bent the knee King Robert
generously allowed Lord Balin to retain
his title and castle the price of peace
was custom the only soul of balance to
survive as foolish rebellion would be
taken as a hostage against future
treasonous my father even volunteered to
foster the boy himself I suspect to make
Theon Greyjoy a different man than his
father who would bring honor and Duty to
the Iron Islands when he returned his
heir so my mother's silent fear came
true and my father returned with another
child
Theon ate with us played with us and
fought with us once the great bond
between my father and Robert Baratheon
United the realm against the Mad King
and brought him to justice for his
crimes
now another monster sits on the Iron
Throne
and another debt of blood is old my
family Theon is my murdered father's
ward I am my murdered father's son like
my father and robber bound in blood if
not by blood we are brothers